we pride ourselves on our legal system
we know we should be proud because
foreigners choose to come here to use it
they do say knowing that the judge
before who may appear cannot be bribed
or threatened or bullied into doing
anything other than applying the law
that sense of integrity extends
throughout the system not just for those
who use it but among those who work
within it and try to preserve its
dignity and efficacy as a result our
courts dispense justice with a degree of
equity that means they are still
considered among the fairest in the
world we are in danger of taking this
inheritance for granted great damage has
already been done our legal system is
regularly threatened and often wholly
unsupported by those whose duty it is to
protect it changes in its function and
its funding have gouged chunks out of
the high legal principles that we
presumed were inviolable access to
justice for all no matter what your
background or your bank balance a high
quality judiciary both to enforce the
law and to make it a fair swift and
equal hearing we may believe that we are
a long way away from the corrupted legal
systems that encourage foreigners to
litigate in our courts rather than their
own where only money or political
failure favor can ensure your freedom or
a favorable judge judgment we would be
mistaken while the legal system is in
need of reform the cumulative effect of
poorly targeted funding cuts over
several decades has seriously
compromised the criminal law and
threatens the principle of good and fair
justice both for victims and defendants
access to the family and civil courts
for those without means is now skeletal
falling pay and overwhelming workloads
have meant that finding new judges is as
difficult as keeping the ones we already
have something made no easier by
public attacks from those who should
know better the law and by extension the
country is threatened by an insidious
form of corruption that is just as
damaging as the more obvious kind the
gradual but irreparable erosion in trust
in our legal system and its ability to
dispense justice in a situation against
is forgive me its ability to dispense
justice is a situation against which we
must all protect ourselves for should we
slip further into it all of us will bear
the cost lawyers often say the law is
important even to those who aren't are
unlikely to set foot in a courtroom
because as the truism goes none of us
know what life might throw at us any of
us may become the unexpected victim of a
terrible crime or a false accusation but
the laws Reach is far wider than this
the decisions made in courts across our
country touch our daily lives somehow no
matter how far removed we think we might
be or whether we notice our ability to
buy and sell and to invest are made
possible by a legal system that is
trusted to enforce a contract fairly
from the cost of our household insurance
to the ability to hold our government
and its institutions to account good and
bad decisions by the law reach us all in
the end the law seems removed because
the archaic rituals and language of the
court below the fact that our system is
a living thing it deals with the most
contemporary of problems reflecting
society back at itself this is why
everyone should have an interest in
protecting what we know our justice
system candy at its best the law is
human justice designed and enforced it
will always therefore be imperfect it
makes mistakes it is slow sometimes
chaotic sometimes illogical it cracks
and at times crumbles but it remains a
pillar upon which
country is founded where it to break the
stability of our nation would break too
and we would all be the poorer for it
did you know that the Institute of arson
ideas also has a podcast philosophy for
our times brings you the biggest ideas
from the leading thinkers around the
world every week search for philosophy
for our times and subscribe today on
your favorite podcast platform
SoundCloud or iTunes to make sure you
never miss an episode